um by the way should we should we read
should we read some comments from of
people roasting oh that's on takedown of
all the things that
could have poked the bear i would not
have thought it was dana white
i i was blown away i'm like people
really
they really like this guy
it's wild
i mean no regardless if you like them or
not you
it it's not controversial
to
be aware of the fact that he's like an
absurd human as are we all but like
especially him you know yeah
yeah
y'all are so dry you're just repeating
him no we're not when when did dana
white say this tastes like a care bears
[ __ ] he never said that
was that in the tick tock uh something
like that
maybe
not even a fan of dana fly
false
false
[Laughter]
if you weren't a dan if you weren't a
fan of dana you wouldn't care
you wouldn't be commenting on it you
wouldn't give a [ __ ] you wouldn't care
if it wasn't funny you just like you
would you would have scrolled past you
would have saw dana white and just kept
it moving
i've been watching all these vids and i
swear to god it feels so awkward
watching these two trying to make
literally anything funny in quotes
why did you put that in quotations
funny this just shows that not everyone
should have a podcast not one thing they
said was fun oh yeah user 706.
cool man tell us more from your dad's
internet
[Applause]
oh we got we got roasted people we
really got torn a new one
yeah so people people really like
dana white yeah that much i mean people
clearly love our jokes even more like
all the love they have for dana white
they loved us even more well they
weren't our jokes we were just repeating
what he right we yeah we were just
repeating the part where he was like
what the [ __ ] is good i'm on sick shot
to howler head
[Music]
i'm [ __ ] blacked out
let's use some cotton candy [ __ ]
i found it
this tastes like a piece of the earth
from the sam i am book
that one's kind of neat you know i'll
give you that that was kind of
i feel like i just take this [ __ ]
bit into my little pony's titties like
come on
he didn't say that
he did not say that never said that
we know we what he didn't say it also
bro
all right let me calm down it's a cut
stop calm down you're trying you're
trying trying to wait too hard
i'm cringing just knock it off
how can you not sit here and think that
a grown man promoting a cotton candy
burrito isn't hysterical this dude is in
the business of people no he's not a
great he's not even just a grown man
he's the [ __ ] founder of of the
league where two dudes beat the [ __ ] out
of each other yeah yeah he's also a
hardcore trumper this guy is like
do you know what i'm saying he's absurd
yeah i mean i don't even know if like
did he no it was the fertitta brothers
that found the ufc but he's like the
he's like the guy he's the president
he's i think even more than founding it
he's the face of people beating the [ __ ]
out of each other yeah that's what i
mean he's the face of people
annihilating each other that's the
funniest part to me is all these people
just saying this [ __ ]
and here i go here i go ready
i've probably been watching mma longer
than half these [ __ ] dude
yeah i've literally been watching mma
for like 10 [ __ ] years
these [ __ ] idiots and keep going
these [ __ ] idiots make this make this
a copy pasta
i've been watching mma for 10 [ __ ]
years see how many years i've been on
the mat
how many years i've had the gloves on
recreationally
how many meet and greets i've been to
i was the first guy at donald cowboy
cerrone's meet-and-greet you know what
he told me
not gonna lie man you got a pretty sick
anaconda because i gave him an anaconda
for a picture
it's not a reference to my penis that's
a reference to a highly technical
grappling move
so i don't care if you're a fan of dana
white if you're not a fan of dana white
i've earned my place
to make a few jokes
in this here mma world okay
spoken my peace
there you go there you go guys
i want to see that in the comments on
the next 50 episodes dude i've never
seen two guys try so hard to be funny
straight up
don't talk [ __ ] about joe and do not
talk [ __ ] about dana
because honestly if i'm being completely
honest with you they could both beat
your asses not only could they [ __ ] you
up what have you ever done with your
life dude you got a stupid ass podcast
you even know [ __ ] about [ __ ] friday
dude for some people [ __ ] friday is a
point of positivity and you guys are
just here being negative making weak-ass
jokes some people that's the highlight
of our week in fact we work all week
to look forward to [ __ ] fridays
every time because on fridays we like to
[ __ ] it we like to say [ __ ] it and we
like to [ __ ] it
every time dana puts on a pay-per-view i
make sure i throw 70 bones at dana just
so he can comfortably do a [ __ ]
friday and bring happiness to my life
what do you do dude you just sit there
and talk [ __ ]
yeah wait speaking of which
hold on i think there might have been
what what happened what was before
saturday the last week oh saturday um
the day before saturday
friday
friday friday which means
that it would have been
another [ __ ] friday oh
i thought you're talking about something
go ahead and
fighting related but yes there would
have been another [ __ ] friday so
let's give it to our boys exactly i
think i think it's right here let's see
what's up everybody it's [ __ ] friday
here again at ufc headquarters and i
don't know if you guys actually make and
eat the [ __ ] that i try here but if you
haven't
let this be the one
today chef eric has come up with deep
fried uncrustables all right start off
with white bread
and spread raspberry jam on it
then melt some white chocolate add that
on top
use a circular mold to cut off the crust
fry it to 400 degrees for about 15
seconds on each side
and dust it off with white powdered
sugar
it's [ __ ] hot
[Music]
it's too hot
it's incredible
i think it's the best thing that we've
ever done on [ __ ] friday
if you haven't tried one of these yet
let this be the one
[ __ ] it dude
[Applause]
[ __ ] it don't say [ __ ] dude
and you know what we do here on [ __ ]
fridays
i don't want to hear you say i don't
want you oh see you try so hard to be
funny i didn't want to see it
sorry don't even [ __ ] try dude dude
dude that looks really good actually
i would love to try that
when he was like
chef eric has come up with the best
possible thing
in all of [ __ ] friday
that was good right
yeah
that was good
and when he was like
i don't know if you guys even make any
of the [ __ ] that i eat at home but
that part was [ __ ] that was that was
so good that was good dude you sound
exactly like him man and then when he
was like
put down a scoop of jelly
and then some white chocolate on top
you put the other slice on top then you
put the mold over it
yeah then you fry it for 15 seconds each
side and you pull it out
so good good
and that one part where he said
it's too hot
i just put it in my mouth i burned the
roof of my mouth again
chef what is this guy's name chef dude
[ __ ] you chef eric why don't you ever
warn me about this [ __ ] you're fired you
piece of [ __ ] i see now you're just
trying too hard you're just trying to
you just
you're just repeating what he said dude
it wasn't even good
yeah you really shouldn't have a podcast
man
[Laughter]
you know all things considered though
that [ __ ] friday was kind of boring
yeah it really was he didn't really
deliver that was a bad set it's okay
that was a bad one it's okay
it's hard to compete man dana has
bangers all the time with [ __ ] friday
i know
dawg someone brought up a hilarious
point where they were like man if they
didn't like you guys making fun of
[ __ ] friday they will not like when
you clown dana's head progression size
they will not appreciate that at all
that was an old one though i know like
last year yeah we should we should
definitely not talk about it we don't
want them to find it
sorry guys
you know what sorry you know what i love
is like
what
these dudes are literally
in love with [ __ ] kingpin from batman
in real life
like dirt yeah they they like are in
love with like lex luthor on steroids
how do you even care i just don't
understand how you even care about
someone making fun of dana white
i got to let it go i don't know i don't
know i don't know even if you respect a
guy you can still respect him and
i mean you can make fun of anyone you
know you're like you know everyone's got
weird you know you make people you guys
all you do is rip on me
yeah
all the time you know
[Music]
all these comments about me looking old
i've never seen people try so hard to be
so funny dude yeah honestly these are
super cringe
all you guys are doing is just repeating
memes all the time
it's just proof that not everyone should
be able to comment on a tick tock dude
exactly dude
yeah what's whatever it's fine no need
to get upset